[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
May 23rd I'm J.R Wellen for the Wall
Street Journal
consumers are digging deeper to pay for
everything from diapers to food to
handbags even while we hear that the
inflation rate ticks lower every month
Wall Street Journal reporter Suzanne
Kepner joins us to explain why companies
keep raising prices so Suzanne inflation
is considerably lower than where it was
a year ago but consumer confidence has
also come down why are consumers feeling
that way so there are a lot of signs in
the economy that point to a potential
recession we've seen a lot of layoffs
especially among white collar jobs and
the pace of inflation over the past few
years has really crimped consumers
budgets we saw in some recent spending
data from the government consumers are
dipping more into their savings to make
purchases so with consumers feeling more
skittish compared to several months ago
why do companies feel comfortable still
raising prices the companies that are
able to continue raising prices are
selling things that either consumers
really need or really want so it's
either a sign of necessity or or a sign
of brand heat like your brand is so hot
and consumers really want what you're
selling they're willing to pay up for it
what are some examples of that well Kate
Spade has this purse that's in the shape
of a dog that cost 500 it is one of
their best selling Handbags and for a
lot of people that's not an inexpensive
outlay 500 for what is a really very
novelty bag it's certainly not a
necessity but they are you know selling
like hot cakes where are we seeing this
in terms of household products well
Procter Gamble said recently that
consumers continue to spend even though
it raised prices about 10 percent in the
last quarter and they're expending
heavily on things like Pampers and Tide
detergent and stuff they really need
what kind of a situation is that putting
consumers in consumers are having to
make choices right and we're no longer
in the kind of free spending days that
we experienced as we just came out of
the pandemic you know a year or two ago
and consumers are really having to
decide guide you know how much they need
or want something now over the past two
years we've often heard companies blame
things like labor costs and supply chain
constraints as reasons for them
continuing to raise prices are those
things still factoring into the price
hikes well certainly you know all kinds
of costs continue to be elevated as
inflation remains above pre-pandemic
levels but we are seeing some signs that
the price increases might be going
Beyond covering those higher costs in
the first quarter we had a lot of
companies reporting margins that were
growing for the first time in about six
quarters which suggests that the price
increases are greater than their cost
increases how much of this has to do
with as long as consumers are willing to
pay the price companies will continue to
charge that price well I think it's you
know what the market will bear and it's
sort of the way capitalism works right
is as long as consumers are willing to
pay the price companies are going to
charge that price and they're going to
keep raising prices until they kind of
see some pushback from consumers but
does it seem like this is almost a
dangerous numbers game for consumers are
these companies running into the
potential danger of reaching a Tipping
Point where consumers are just going to
balk and walk away well I think we saw
with Disney announcing plans to close
one of its experiential resorts at
Disney world that it was very expensive
and consumers were sort of not willing
to pay that much so you are starting to
see some signs where consumers are
balking and companies have to kind of
walk back a little bit so you have weary
consumers whose wallets have been
stretched thin and their overall Outlook
has soured what are companies getting
out of raising prices well it's a sign
to investors and the stock market that
your brand is strong so like tapestry
which owns coaching Kate Spade they talk
about brand heat and they actually
started their price increases before the
pandemic it had nothing at the time to
do with inflation they they were trying
to elevate their brand by reducing
Supply reducing discounts improving
quality and all those things allowed
them to raise prices it's a sign that
your brand is is hot and that is
something that companies want to signal
to investors and we've had periods of
rising prices and maxed out consumers
before is there a history lesson
companies could learn about how
consumers eventually respond well I
think the key in all of this is the job
market and if we really start to see
unemployment tick up that's going to
really impede on consumers ability to
spend that's Wall Street Journal
reporter Suzanne Kepner
and that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen The Wall Street Journal
[Music]